six ans que hf prévention santé ne
s'était pas rendu à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pour réaliser des tests de dépistage du
vih en raison du coc vide les campagnes
ont été moins nombreux selon le
directeur ce dernier se montre très
inquiet effectivement on s'aperçoit
qu'avec la crise qu vides il y a une
vraie problématique sur le dépistage du
vih puisque pendant presque deux ans il
y a un retard de 43 % de dépistage du
vih ce qui a occasionné 14 % de
personnes séropositives qui n'ont pas pu
être diagnostiqués l'année dernière d'où
l'importance d'augmenter le nombre de
dépistages ces derniers sont gratuits et
anonymes et le résultat est connu en une
minute chrono que je vais lui piquer le
petit bout du doigt avec le petit à
petit lens est je vais récupérer les
gouttes de sang dans la petite poire qui
va me permettre de pouvoir récolter le
sens pour pouvoir le mélange est dans le
produit numéro un qui est le dit blanc
donc il faut bien diluer le temps pour
que le sang puisse passer à l'intérieur
de la membrane ensuite le s'en passer je
vais prendre le numéro 2 qui est le
développeur c'est lui qui va rechercher
justement les anticorps passe à travers
le 106 mille deux cents nouveaux cas de
vih sont recensés chaque année dont 13
pour cent des personnes sont âgées de
moins de 25 ans sensibilisé les jeunes
est donc primordial puisque un quart des
15 24 ans pense que le sida peut
s'attraper en embrassant une personne
séropositive
l'épidémie continue à faire des ravages
mais malgré tout il ya aussi pas mal de
gens qui ont l'impression que le vih
c'est pour les autres et notamment les
jeunes j'ai décidé de venir me faire
dépister pour pouvoir montrer un petit
peu à mes potes que c'était important de
le faire que c'était une bonne action et
que ça pouvait être que bénéfique pour
eux en france le virus du sida touche
plus de 170 mille personnes